you know the beauty of being black in
this society is the black has always
been an inclusive definition white has
always been an exclusive definition
thank you know one of the challenges for
white people next 40 years is to figure
out how to have a more inclusive picture
of who their families are of who they
are I you know I grew up in a family who
wear my father's Y - my mother's black
but if we're honest exception maybe the
two or three generations in-between on
the black side most most of the male
parent it's hard to calm a parent if you
know you you raped the mother and lots
of the male parents were white for
generations the growing up as a black
kid with a white father who loves you
who affirms you who is who was part of
your life is fundamentally different
then what people my family were
subjected to in the 19th century or the
18th century but unfortunately it
doesn't it doesn't change the old racial
order I think we need to in our in this
society
let the old racial order just stay where
it is not seek to improve upon it not
try to create more racial categories
because all that does is it makes ray
stick around longer and the reality is
that race is a lie built on on a lie you
know it's it's the the lot of the the
first lie is that is that people are
different that's somehow skin color or
hair texture is more significant than
then eye color or the shape of one's
feet the second lie built on top of that
is that then there's a hierarchy that
that more significant difference you
know the the color showing up is brown
on your skin rather than brown on your
hair or whatever is somehow more
significant and there's some sort of
hierarchy that the lighter you are the
street of your hair the better you are
in you know Obama Oh
you know dick Parsons whoever is gonna
Blanc Lynch and alt have blown that out
of the water President Obama Michelle
Obama for the country right the trick
now is for us to really incorporate that
into our family lives and for for people
to not just I guess be led by their
children who for whom race is is is just
much less significant but the Potala
bleed their children there and or or at
least follow willingly